man you Darksiders fans are in for a  treat  I'm not even gonna tease it I'll just  say that I'm Tony and we're gonna jump  right into this GameSpot news update  Darksiders 3 is totally happening we've  played as war we play as death and now  we'll take fury for a spin she's the  most unpredictable of the horsemen using  her magic and weapons to hunt down the  seven deadly sins thanks to some  screenshots from the games Amazon  listing we've gotten a look at a few of  the post-apocalyptic environments - and  there's definitely more to come so make  sure you're subscribed to be the first  to know all the new stuff Darksiders 3  is headed to ps4 Xbox one and PC in 2018  it's being developed by gunfire games a  new studio where many members of the old  Darksiders team at vigil games are now  employed perhaps we'll see more at e3 -  for now you can check out the trailer  for another post-apocalyptic adventure  code vein  [Music]  you